dudes check it out
it's the foot
what the heck are those foot losers
doing here last I checked this was those
purple dragon losers turf huh losers as
much as I prefer to use my head my guts
screaming that this is just a precursor
to something larger and like out
screaming that it's time for an
extra-large with anchovies and sausage
forget it Mikey
we need to find out what the foot are up
to let's move
just NGOs
guys can hear me apparently bebop is
planning something big and whatever it
is it can't be good
yeah
career is going crazy guys be super
careful
lots of items ready for you and Dallaire
drop by when you get a chance
brah
though righteous
Oh
yeah
yeah
guys
remember guys if you ever need any items
just stop by the lair to get some from
splitter guys it audience we've gathered
I've been able to pin we bee-bop's
location these are the bank boarding on
your tea glass yeah
yeah
Oh super rare item lucky
that's my fastball special did
for anything don't get caught off guard
smash some shells
so guys if bebop is trying to break into
the safe does that mean concern
vo can you talk to this guy yes he's
trying to bring home the bacon huh
not you too
Oh dizzy
get this bro
laughs that was close
guys little help
you got this bro
to the drawing board
we got this bro
funny
that can't move my limbs
you got this bro you sure took your time
yeah
total bummer
he's been knocked out you're gonna have
to Boulder with just the three of you
yeah guys a little help
well that's the thing that just happened
you're going to chew looking good
to the drawing board
booty
me
yeah
that's a thing that just happened we got
this bro
Thanks
I don't feel so well
three of you can't move my limbs you got
this bro
guys little help
with just three of you
Oh dizzy
skull ring in life the Bell
pull yourself together
I owe you a slice
lights out too
Oh
pull yourself together
Leyton never did
you green dweebs think you got the best
old bebop do you wheels are all wrong
cuz B mobster best Aries and that little
piggy ran way away went all the way home
yeah but he dropped something on the way
what is it done
cash and lots of it but why rob a bank
just to leave the money behind yeah no
kiddin
imagine what someone could do with all
that loot hello Rupert's pizzeria yeah
I'd like to order two thousand extra
large cheese and pepperoni specials and
five thousand orders of breadsticks for
pickup please
ah nevermind dude wrong number
you